there's always deadlines and you know
our deadline is as a rocket-launching so
you can't really miss that there's a lot
of hard work a lot of 20-hour days that
go into that with people right now and
the cleanroom building satellites that
you're not gonna go home very very early
this evening probably um Eureka apart
from spire global one of the founders
there and I'm 27 years old
spire Global's a data services company
with space-based data as a source so
what we use for that as a constellation
of nano satellites so the satellites are
kind of you know wine bottle size
satellites if you think of them as
porcupine with solar panels and wings on
it a lot of antennae sticking out that
kind of thing you don't do imagery
everything we do is RF spectrum based
you listen to radio waves really and
they can range to a variety a variety of
things you can listen to things that are
transmitting on the earth you could look
at other satellites you can look at GPS
satellites you can listen to ships I
think what is it 80 or 90 percent of the
world's global trade is through ships to
container ships on the ocean so if you
have knowledge about where all that
happens you can have a huge impact on
all kinds of different industries all
kinds of different people
back when I was 14 16 or something start
playing guitar and then you buy these
guitar effect battle you were really
expensive so I started building them
myself it was a lot of solder and the
wires and all that kind of stuff and
then probably went to college to kind of
do the same thing there learn more about
it learn more about the components and
how you really build systems today I
love technology I love getting my hands
dirty and soldering wires and poking at
things with ropes if you're not having
fun doing it you're not gonna be able to
keep doing it especially early on when
it's 20-hour days
you